we've interviewed Fox News moles before
we interviewed Joe Muto on the show
really good interview that we're linking
to on YouTube we've interviewed Fox News
employees before david shuster linking
to that interview on youtube excellent
interview and as you might know I was
recently on Fox news along with
right-wing radio host Tom Giordano and
we were hosted in a sort of debate by
Leland Vitter Dinh as some of you know
it very quickly became two against one
when I appeared on Fox News I have now
received an email from someone claiming
to be a low-level person at the weekend
Fox News show that I was on it's called
America's News house headquarters who
says that immediately after I appeared
on Fox News it was said that I would
never be invited back after that
appearance this is the email I received
okay you are going to now have all the
information that I have hey David I'm
writing to you from a throwaway email
account because I don't want to be
identified I am a very low-level person
who is at Fox News during their daytime
weekend shows I was there when you were
on after the appearance I heard a
conversation between producers who say
you aren't ever going to be back on Fox
News it wasn't clear why it wasn't a
long conversation but it was clear they
did not like your so they use the wrong
you're I'm including that in the
transcript they didn't like your
appearance and said he isn't ever coming
back keep up the good work so I have no
way of verifying this right I have no
way to know whether this is true I know
I haven't been invited back but it's
only been a couple of weeks I don't
think it's reasonable to assume I would
have already been back right I also
don't know why I'd be blacklisted as a
result of that appearance I mean it yeah
for people who say David you owned them
it was a very reasonable within the
bounds of what Fox News expects segment
it's not like I did such damage to the
conservative brand obviously I didn't
and I would argue that even Kyle
kolinsky who was on a few months ago did
just as well as I did he was recently
back on so I don't know who you know I
don't know the the truth of who this
person is and if they actually heard
this conversation if true it's utterly
and completely insane I think Kyle did
well the first time but he did much
better and a
he would even say this the second time
around so that makes me question whether
or not FoxNews would have a back on for
a third time sure I also thought you did
really well and you know these Fox News
types the producers they just want these
weak liberals on who will push over and
I get it you know credit Trump engage in
the argument but clearly not perform
very well well they want the like the
Juan Williams types yeah well I am
certainly no Juan Williams that's for
sure but I was thinking imagine if they
didn't like how white I looked on camera
which of course was because of their
lighting like it that that would be
absolutely and totally insane but if
anybody has more information I would
love to hear more and quite frankly I
don't think they even think about me
enough to think about blacklisting me
they would just not invite me back right
like black lists exist I've talked to
Mike Papantonio about being blacklisted
at certain networks I've talked to Sam
cedar about black lists I just don't
think one eight minute appearance that I
did that wasn't even that remarkable is
enough to get them to care enough to
blacklist me yeah and I really wonder
like the person who wrote you this email
are they some closeted liberal over
there at Fox News good work yeah I mean
why are they working for Fox News that
we know that Fox News which I believe
does use a lot of Union tech people like
camera people a lot of them are left
wingers this again what Joe Mutoh told
us the Fox News mole and what I think
David Shuster I don't remember if on-air
or off air talked to me about so I don't
know exactly what the position is of
this person I'd love to know more and
hopefully there will be some follow-up
but at this point I have not seen any
definitive evidence that I've been
blacklisted from Fox News it would be
somewhat of an accomplishment to get
myself blacklisted after just one live
appearance right like that would be
interesting I mean it would be better if
you went out with a bang though like
insulted their entire news yeah
headquarters if I suspected that I was
maybe at risk of being blacklisted I
would have gone in and tried to burn the
entire place down figuratively of course
in criticizing the mere existence of Fox
News